hi everyone arpan here and this is ayan
my brother
he is
the nerd medic finally a med student
from arjuna medical college india
and i am a final year graduate student
from tata institute of fundamental
research india together we are bringing
a new video series which is known as
hashtag biomedicine
as you guys already know with each
passing day the difference between
medicine and biology is reducing
substantially now biology is getting
reduced into a unified subject known as
the biomedicine and that's why we're
bringing a new series which will help
you to integrate better and understand
better the concepts without the
understanding of basic and core biology
medicine cannot be understood from a
holistic fashion
similarly if you don't understand the
clinical applications it's very
difficult to grasp the basic biological
concepts and that is why we are bringing
this new video series to integrate these
fundamental concepts with the clinical
approach and take you from the lab to
the clinic
and that is why this video series would
be really useful
so don't forget to subscribe his channel
the nerd medic all the links are
provided in the description don't forget
to subscribe my channel as well so
see you in next video if you have any
suggestion put it in the comment we
would be happy to hear your suggestions